CLANCY CHILDS: Hello.
Thank you for attending.
In this session, we're going
to be speaking about two
Google products, Google AdSense
and Google Analytics,
which are now integrating with
Google BigQuery, Google's big
data analysis and
query engine.
My name's Clancy Childs.
I'm a product manager for
Google Analytics.
LOUIS COLLARD: I'm
Louis Collard.
I'm a software engineer
on AdSense.
DUNCAN MCKIE: And I'm
Duncan Mckie.
I work for Gumtree.com.
CLANCY CHILDS: A key design
principle for all Google
products is to make sure that
they are easy to use by the
average user.
This means that for reporting
products, like Google
Analytics and AdSense, we really
focus on making sure
that users can get to the data
very quickly, with very low
latency, and don't require a lot
of deep domain knowledge
about the data that's contained
within those reports.
Really, the idea is that we want
these users to quickly
get to the data and get some
insights out of it and then go
and take action.
However, we also know that
there's a lot of users at our
clients-- a lot of our clients
have in their teams data
scientists, data-savvy analysts
and developers, who
really want a much more granular
access to the data
within these products.
So for instance, some of the use
cases that we see here are
the developers that want a
SQL-like query interface so
they can actually get into the
granular data and really make
complex queries on the data
within there to sort of solve
specific problems or optimize.
They also tend to do things like
use some of the business
class, the enterprise class
visualization tools, things
like Tableau, which some of
you may be familiar with.
What they look for is getting
this data into Tableau and
doing things like building
enterprise-wide dashboards so
that a company can see at a
glance how their business is
doing using data from
different data sets.
And a lot of times, what we've
heard is that these companies
want to get their AdSense and
Analytics data into those
visualization tools as well.
These users also tend to really
rely on their own data
warehouses, so in many cases,
what they would like to do is
join up data from different
data sources
into a single place.
So for instance, an online hotel
booking site may have a
database that contains all of
their profit margins for each
online booking.
And what they would like to do
is join that with data from,
let's say, Google Analytics and
be able to say not only
what are my most profitable
transactions, but actually
what were the online user
behaviors that led to those
transactions?
So they want to be able to join
this data all together in
the data warehouses.
Likewise, they may want to use
this granular data as an input
into other business
applications
that they may have.
For instance, an online
retailer may have a
personalization engine
application that they've built
for their home page.
And they want to take data from
Google Analytics and from
their CRM system, join that data
together, and when a user
lands on their home page, have
that application display to
that user a personalized view
of particular products that
that user may be interested
in purchasing.
So all of these different use
cases really require a very
deep access to the data
contained within these
products for these data
scientist users.
LOUIS COLLARD: Thanks, Clancy.
So this is where BigQuery
comes in.
It's Google's big data
analysis engine.
And it's been designed from the
beginning with these kinds
of use cases in mind.
So we decided the best thing
to do would be to leave our
existing interfaces as they
are for standard users and
make our data available in
BigQuery so that data
scientists can get the access
they need and take advantage
of BigQuery's existing
functionality.
So there's a few features I'd
like to call out which we
think make this a
really good fit.
So firstly scale, you can query
billions of rows of data
interactively.
So you can type an SQL-like
statement into your browser
and watch the results come
back almost straightaway.
You can also query from the
command line or from the API.
And as Clancy mentioned, you're
probably going to want
to join the Google data we're
making available with some of
your own data.
And Big Query gives you a
couple of options here.
You can either upload your data
into BigQuery and do all
your analysis in the cloud,
which can be pretty
cost-effective as it saves you
having to own and maintain an
equivalent hardware and
software stack.
Or if you are already using
some third-party data
warehousing and analysis
solution, then BigQuery
already has good integration
with a number of them.
So if you're using one of those,
you can just import the
data from BigQuery into your
existing solution.
If you are going to do that, you
can still take advantage
of BigQuery to reduce the volume
of data that you have
to import, either just by being
selective about the rows
that you import or by
performing some
pre-aggregation in BigQuery.
So I'm going to talk now
about the AdSense data
we're making available.
Hopefully, this looks familiar
to some of you.
It's the same data which
is available in
the UI and the API.
And we've got this split
into five tables.
The basic DailyReport table
exposes all of the common
dimensions.
And then the AdUnit,
CustomChannel, and UrlChannel
dimensions are each available
in their own respective
tables, which all expose
all of the common
dimensions as well.
And lastly, we've got the Domain
table, which exposes
Date, Ad Client, Product,
and Domain.
So all of these tables expose
the same five raw AdSense
metrics that you see here.
You'll notice that CPC,
CTR, and RPM are
missing from that list.
That's because those are all
derived from these metrics,
which is something you can do
easily as part of your query.
So compared to the UI, this
gives you quite a bit of extra
flexibility, in that you can
request any combination of the
dimensions and metrics that are
available in those tables.
And you can run much
larger reports than
you can in the UI.
The data is still retrieved
live, so if you're watching
for updates throughout the
day, you'll see those
reflected in BigQuery.
And the data will match
what you see in
the UI at all times.
And obviously, it's still free
to query this data, so you
won't be charged by BigQuery
for querying these tables.
I've got here a very simple
query, just to retrieve your
top channels by earnings, just
to give you an idea of what it
would look like, really.
You can see in blue where it's
selecting and grouping by
custom_channel_id.
And then in green, we're
retrieving and
ordering by the earnings.
You probably already know your
top five custom channels, so
more interesting might be
channels that have grown the
most month-on-month.
This is something that's not
readily available in the UI,
but in BigQuery is quite
easy to retrieve.
We've got here a query which is
joining the results of two
subqueries.
In blue, we're retrieving
a customer
channel report for January.
And then in green-- this is
truncated so it fits--
the same thing, but
for February.
Then the outer query in red is
joining the results of those
two subqueries on
custom_channel_name, then
calculating the delta on
the number of clicks
and ordering by that.
So if I switch to the BigQuery
browser tool, you can see I've
got the full query here.
If I just press Run on that, we
should pretty quickly get
back an answer.
And here we've got some
helpfully named custom
channels and the number of
additional clicks they got in
February compared to January.
Lastly, we mentioned third
party integration.
I'm going to show you a few of
the kinds of things that you
can do using Tableau, which is
one of the products that
already integrates
with BigQuery.
On the left-hand side here,
we've got the dimensions and
metrics that are available
in the BigQuery table.
And we're looking here at
a graph of earnings from
November to end of January.
So you'll notice there's
a fairly strong weekly
seasonality to the data.
And then we've got a much bigger
dip here, which turns
out to be Christmas.
Interesting, nothing
particularly actionable at
this point.
So let's dig a bit deeper.
If we add, say, platform, then
we can very quickly see an
interesting trend pop up after
Christmas, which is that the
orange and red sections, which
are mobile and tablet devices,
show quite a noticeable uplift
in revenue after Christmas.
So that would seem to indicate
people got some new devices
for Christmas, so that
kind of makes sense.
So we could decide to stop here
and go away and optimize
our site for mobile.
In this example, we actually
have different sites for
different countries.
So it's probably worth checking
if all the countries
are showing the same trends.
So if I just exclude desktop for
now, seeing as we're not
interested in that at the
moment, and then if I merge
these two together, seeing as
they're behaving roughly the
same, change this to a line, and
then add Country, then we
see another interesting trend.
So our two main earners here are
Australia in brown and the
UK in gray.
And it looks like it's
been a pretty good
Christmas for the UK.
The uplift in earnings there is
a lot more noticeable than
for Australia.
So at this point, we can go away
and optimize our UK site
for mobile first, knowing
that that will
have the biggest impact.
We're pleased to announce that
there's a beta version of this
integration available for all
AdSense publishers from today.
All you need to do to get
started is sign up for a
BigQuery project using the same
Google login as you use
for your AdSense accounts.
And that's it.
Then you can go and start
querying the tables.
We've got step-by-step
instructions on all of this on
the AdSense Developer site.
As I said, it is a beta,
so there probably
will be some bugs.
If you find them, please let
us know so we can fix them.
And the best place to do
that is on the forum.
Thanks very much.
I'm going to pass
back to Clancy.
CLANCY CHILDS: Cool.
[APPLAUSE]
CLANCY CHILDS: Thanks
a lot, Louis.
Similar to the AdSense
integration with BigQuery,
we're here today to announce
what we're doing with Google
Analytics and BigQuery.
So what are we announcing?
We are targeting in September
of this year a public launch
where Google Analytics Premium
clients will be able to have
their data from Google Analytics
Premium imported
into BigQuery.
What we're doing today is
we're also opening up a
developer group for developers
that may be interested in
working with this BigQuery
integration.
So I'll give you in a few
minutes a link that will take
you to a form where you can
register your interest in this
particular integration.
What are we actually
exporting?
It's a daily export of all of
the data within a Google
Analytics profile into
BigQuery, so
it's a daily export.
And the schema, which we'll be
sharing on the developers
group shortly, takes the shape
of every row in BigQuery in
this integration corresponds to
a session or visit in the
Google Analytics profile.
And so it will have information
on there like any
sort of visitor or visit-level
custom dimensions or
variables, things like
traffic source.
All of that visit-level
information is in each row.
But also within each of those
rows is a nested sequence of
all the hits that happened
in that visit.
So this would mean that, as
it's in a sequence, in the
order that they occurred,
every page view, event,
e-commerce transaction, and if
you're using the mobile SDKs
for Google Analytics,
things like
exceptions and screen views.
So you really actually get the
hit-level data, as well as the
session-level data in each
of these rows in
the BigQuery export.
Where possible, we are using the
same dimension and metric
names that we use for
the Core Reporting
API in Google Analytics.
We're using those as the column
names in BigQuery.
So if you already use the Core
Reporting API for Google
Analytics, you will have a
certain amount of familiarity
with the dimension names and
metric names in BigQuery.
One important note is that at
launch, this is going to
contain first-party data.
That means any of the data
that's actually collected by
either the Google Analytics
measurement protocol or any of
the tracking code or the
SDKs for mobile apps.
There's some data in Google
Analytics, for instance, GOIP
lookup, so the geography data,
that's actually post-processed
into Google Analytics.
And that data might
not be available
at launch in September.
However, we're going to
continually look to expand the
number of dimensions and metrics
that we can pass
through in this export
into BigQuery.
Starting today, if you're
interested in learning more
about this integration, you can
go to this short link or
scan the QR code.
There will be a form there.
And that form, if you just
explain to us what you're
hoping to do, we're just trying
to collect some data
about exactly how people are
looking forward to using this
integration.
And we'll add you to the
group, where we will be
sharing things like the schema
when it's ready to be shared,
things like a sample data set,
and all that sort of
information especially as we
come up to launch on this.
Please join.
And we'll be posting everything
there shortly.
But I can talk about all the
things we're going to do.
What makes a lot more sense
is for me to invite
Duncan McKie up.
Duncan is a senior--
[INAUDIBLE].
DUNCAN MCKIE: I like
to make a bang.
CLANCY CHILDS: So Duncan is a
senior business analyst for
eBay Classifieds Group.
EBay Classified--
are you done?
DUNCAN MCKIE: I think
I'm done.
I think I'm done.
Sorry guys.
CLANCY CHILDS: EBay Classifieds
Group is a Google
Analytics premium client.
They're also one of our larger
AdSense publishers as well.
So we've given Duncan early
access to both of these
integrations.
And he's been able to run a
bunch of queries and do a
bunch of really interesting
things with this.
And he's going to take us
through now some of the demos
that he's prepared.
DUNCAN MCKIE: Thank
you, Clancy.
Sorry, everybody,
for the bang.
Before we get started,
can I just get a
quick show of hands.
How many people managed to
attend the Big Data Mashup
session earlier?
OK.
So we've got quite a
few in the room.
How many people managed to
attend the cross-platform GA
optimization earlier?
OK.
So it's good to see there's
not too many people here.
We'll have lots of new content
for you, then.
OK.
So I'll start off just talking
about who I am.
I work for Gumtree.com,
which is part of
eBay Classifieds Group.
And we had probably
around 42 million
users in the last month.
That's across 27 countries
across the globe.
And unlike other e-commerce
websites, although we connect
our buyers and our sellers
together online initially, a
lot of those actually go
on to transact offline.
So for us, we like to think of
ourselves as a local company
even though we are global.
Now, every time one of our users
interacts with us, be
that on a website, on one of our
apps, or even through one
of our sales teams, that
generates data.
We have petabytes of the stuff
that's in MySQL, Postgres,
Salesforce.
It all gets pulled together
into a massive Teradata
warehouse, which I think at the
last count was round about
10 petabytes.
And we also have an awful lot
of external data as well,
things like Analytics and
AdSense that we'll talk about
today, and a lot of other stuff,
like DFP, Paypal, loads
of different sources of data.
Now we also have a lot
of different brands.
We have a lot of different
sites across the globe.
And that means that each of
our sites and countries
operates independently.
And we have a lot of these
different stores of data.
So all of our challenges
are kind of
magnified by about 30 times.
We have all of our data in
different locations in
different formats.
And the real challenge here is
how do we pull that together
and make it useful?
How do we turn data
into insight?
Now for some of our pro users,
these guys who know how to
connect to the different
systems, they know how to go
in and get this data themselves,
it's fine.
It's a little bit of a
challenge, but it's possible.
However, for our non-power
users, people like our
marketeers, our project
managers, the people who need
the information to be able to
make data-driven decisions,
it's not so easy.
We really want to be able to
pull all of this together and
put it in one place so it's
accessible for them and as
useful as possible.
Now how does BigQuery
fit into this?
Well, I'd like to talk about
how we use Analytics and
AdSense and pull these into
BigQuery, and we can use that
as a central location for some
of our users to get the data.
I'd like to take you through a
couple of different examples.
The first one is this.
We all hate it when this
happens, right?
So picture the scene.
Imagine me as a hipster.
I've just seen this awesome
new blue single-speed bike
that I really want to buy and
make all the other hipster
kids jealous.
And I'm just about to reply to
Clancy, who's selling it, when
I see one of these arrows.
And the worst case is I think,
I'll reply tomorrow.
It'll be fine.
And then the next day, I see
some other kid riding around
the neighborhood on my bike.
The worst case scenario is that
makes me never come back
to Gumtree.
And these kind of issues
actually cost us users.
It's a bad user experience.
And we want to stop it
as much as possible.
Unfortunately, it's not always
simple to do that in the
current Google Analytics user
interface, although there are
some excellent navigational
tools that help us page
backwards and forwards
through pageviews.
Some of our errors are actually
caused by things that
are not pageviews, things like
AJAX requests, things like
events that we're tracking.
Now that we can actually get
the hit-level data in
BigQuery, we can page backwards
and forwards through
these user journeys and really
start to examine them So let's
talk through how we
might do that.
Here you can see a query that's
just requesting some of
our Analytics data.
And in red, you'll see that
we've identified our errors
using a custom variable.
And we're doing a REGEXP_MATCH
on that at the bottom.
Also, you can see in green,
we're pulling out the hit
number for where the
error occurs.
And the information about
the session is in black.
The next step then is to do a
self-JOIN back on this data.
And I'd like to show you a
few things about this.
First of all, in blue you can
see that we're JOINing on the
session data.
Slightly on top of that, you can
see that we're using the
word EACH here.
Now the reason why we're doing
that is because this is a very
big data set.
We're talking millions
of rows.
If it's just a smaller
data set, you
don't need to use EACH.
The final thing I'd
like to show you
is the use of FLATTEN.
Now, because this Analytics
data is in a nested JSON
format, if we want to be able
to JOIN on these repeated
fields, we need to flatten it
out and turn it into a virtual
flat format.
The final step then is to
do one more self-JOIN.
We can use the hit data that
we've pulled out and the visit
data and then pull out all of
the meta-information about
this, things like the hour when
it occurred, the page
name of the hit that directly
preceded our error, and the
number of issues that
we're seeing.
And if we can just switch over
into BigQuery, we can give
that a run.
Now this is scanning through
approximately 14 million rows
just for one of these
derived tables.
We've done that three times,
so that's 42 million rows.
And that takes 10 seconds.
It's blindingly fast.
So having a table of
results is useful.
But the great thing is being
able to plug this into one of
our BI tools, something like
Tableau, which we're seeing a
lot of love for at the moment,
and being able to track this
over time and automate the
reporting process.
From the table, we can just see
that Search has given us
1,775 errors.
But if we actually map this over
time, we get a much more
interesting picture, and we can
see how these errors have
evolved and which of the
different pages have caused
the most errors.
Now we're showing an example
of using errors here.
But the great thing about having
all of our hits in
BigQuery is that we can
investigate any sequence.
So if you were wanting to look
at a conversion funnel, for
example, started with a
pageview, and then the user
goes on to fill in a form and
then later makes a purchase,
we can do that.
It's not currently possible
in the user
interface in Google Analytics.
We can only do a pageview
funnel.
So being able to get that kind
of visibility is really,
really useful.
And the even better thing about
it is we can look at
that historically.
We don't have to apply
this in advance.
The next use case I'd like to
talk about is how we segment
our onsite activity
at Gumtree.
Now whenever an ad is posted,
it has a number of different
attributes.
Some of those are simple, such
as the category and location.
Some of them are a little bit
more complicated, such as
whether it was paid for.
Most of these attributes,
they're fairly static.
They're directly related to the
user experience, and they
don't change too
much over time.
However, our business needs can
be a lot more changing, a
lot more dynamic, be that for
strategic purposes, for HR
reasons, many other reasons.
To illustrate this, let me
give you a quick example.
Let me tell you about
my colleague Ron.
Now Ron's a marketing analyst.
He's a great guy.
I have to say that in
case he's listening.
He's a great guy.
And when we started a couple of
months ago, he came up to
me and said, Duncan, why isn't
all of your traffic organized
by ISBA regions?
Ron, what the heck is
an ISBA region?
I've never heard
of that before.
So he explains to me it's a
non-overlapping television
broadcasting region.
And apparently, it's very
important in allowing us to
assess the online impact of
our offline marketing.
Now, if I wanted to query that
in the user interface, what
I'd have to do is create an
advanced segment and a custom
filter for every
single region.
And then I'd have to query
every one of those
individually every time
Ron wanted this data.
So you may ask, why don't
we just stick
another tag on the site?
Well, we're trying to put down
the amount of data that we're
sending backwards and forwards
to our mobile users.
And if we just aggregated it
up to these regions that he
wants, that might
change in time.
And we're going to lose some
of the granularity that we
really want.
So now that we have BigQuery,
how do we deal with this?
Well, I just say to Ron,
make me a lookup table.
And he'll get Excel out, he'll
type in a load of values, and
he'll make me a lookup table,
which I can then upload into
BigQuery in CSV format.
And we tried to be a little
forward-thinking here, so
instead of just uploading all of
the lookup details for our
ISBA regions, we'll just upload
all of our metadata,
because we've got plenty of
space to play with, right?
So once we've done that,
we need to query
our Analytics data.
So here we're using
a custom variable.
And we're going to call that
location_level_2, because
that's the level that
we want to look at.
And we're just pulling out,
again, the session data and a
little bit of aggregation
just relating to our
pageviews and bounces.
These are the metrics that we
can sum up with, so we can
aggregate them at this stage.
The next step, then, is to
aggregate our lookup table so
that we're only pulling out
the data that we need.
So again, we've got
location_level_2.
But we're also taking
location_level_1, which is our
TV regions that we're
looking at.
We've also applied the filter,
so we're only getting back the
data that we're really
interested in.
Once we've got these two queries
together, we just do a
simple JOIN.
And you can see in red at the
bottom, we're JOINing on
location_level_2 from both
tables and then pulling out
the TV region from
our lookup table.
And in blue, you can see that
it's only at this stage, the
final stage, that we're actually
aggregating that.
So if we just switch over
to BigQuery again,
and we'll run that.
Again, this is running through
millions of sessions.
And it only takes 4
and 1/2 seconds.
So if we switch back to our
presentation, you can see the
results that we've
got back here.
We've managed to pull back all
of our regions that we're
interested in in one query.
It was very quick,
very easy to run.
And we've saved ourselves
a lot of time here.
The great thing about this as
well is we can connect this to
our BI tools.
And as we're only aggregating at
the final point, our users
can then use an interactive
dashboard and cut and slice
this data as they want.
And it will never be sampled.
The final use case I'd like to
talk about actually brings the
AdSense data and the Analytics
data together.
Now for those of you who aren't
familiar with A/B
testing, it's just the practice
of releasing two or
more variants of a particular
development at the same time.
And then we evaluate their
performance according to a
particular metric, a
particular goal.
This helps us to actually
improve our implementation
incrementally.
Now when we're doing that for
AdSense, we're not just
interested in the metrics
that relate to AdSense.
We're not just interested in
clickthrough rates or revenue
or whatever else.
We're interested in how these
ads actually impact on our
overall user experience,
whether it impacts on a
downstream conversion, for
example, or it affects user
engagement.
As a result, some of our
optimization metrics can be a
little bit complicated.
And they have to be derived
from various sources.
Usually this means that we have
to go into the different
user interfaces, query things
separately, and then put them
together in Excel.
It's a little bit long-winded.
And I don't like doing that.
I don't like doing anything
that I can't automate.
Now that we have BigQuery,
we can just automate
the heck out of it.
It's great.
So we'll just write a
quick query on our
AdSense data here.
You can see that we're using
custom_channel_name as our
AdSense group.
And we've just applied a little
tag onto all of our
users in AdSense so that we
can identify them from the
DailyCustomChannelReport.
We've also done that in
Google Analytics.
And we've used a custom variable
again this time.
The final step then, we just
do a very simple query that
JOINs together on those values
of our AdSense test groups.
So if we just switch over again,
jump back into BigQuery
and give that a run, how
long do you think
it's going to take?
5.7 seconds.
That's brilliant.
So if we load up the results
from that, now here we have
our three test groups.
And if I was to just look at the
AdSense metrics, I'd see
that the click-through rate
for testGroup3 is slightly
higher than the others.
And I may stop there and
just pick this group.
However, if we start to combine
our AdSense metrics
with the Analytics metrics,
we can see that actually,
testGroup2 has a higher
number of matched ad
requests per visitor.
That means that these guys are
actually being shown more ads,
and they're possibly
more engaged.
But it could be that actually,
these guys are just coming
back more often, and in a
particular session, they're
seeing less.
So if we also look at our
purely Google Analytics
metrics, our pageviews per
visit, we see that testGroup3
also has a higher value of
pageviews per visit, which
would suggest that these
guys are more engaged.
And then, by being able to look
at the bigger picture and
look at all of our metrics
together, we'd actually picked
testGroup2, which would be
different from the group that
we might have picked
otherwise.
Now this makes it really easy to
get all of the information
that we need in one place.
And the super-awesome thing
about this is if we use the
same Custom Dimension for every
single AdSense test that
we do, we only ever need to
set it up once, and we can
just sit back and be
lazy and be happy.
OK.
Thanks for listening,
everyone.
I'll hand you back to Clancy.
CLANCY CHILDS: Great.
Thanks a lot, Duncan.
I really appreciate that.
[APPLAUSE]
CLANCY CHILDS: So that shows us
the power of what this tool
can do when put in the capable
hands of a data
scientist like Duncan.
And this was actually--
he didn't have much time
to prepare for this.
So it's amazing that just with
this short amount of time,
he's able to start running
really interesting queries
that can actually really help
optimize some of the things
that they're working
on at Gumtree.
So thank you very much
for showing us that.
The next steps for everyone are
if you would like to get
started with BigQuery and
you haven't already,
bigquery.cloud.google.com.
Set up an account.
There's a lot of a public data
samples there already, so if
you just want to start playing
with data in BigQuery, it's
very easy to do.
For Google Analytics and
BigQuery, please register on
this form at this URL.
Or if you want to come by the
Ad Sandbox on the second
floor, we have this information
available as well,
the URL and the one-sheeter.
And again, we're launching this
in September for everyone
in Google Analytics Premium.
For the AdSense and BigQuery
integration that Louis
demonstrated, the beta
is available now.
And there's instructions at this
URL, where you can go and
actually start accessing AdSense
data in BigQuery.
So we're really excited
about this.
This is really a step forward
for getting more granular data
from both of these products
into the hands of data
scientists who are using
the BigQuery tool.
We're looking forward to see
all the really cool things
that everybody's going
to come up with.
And we look forward
to your feedback.
Thank you very much.
We really appreciate it.
We'll open it up
for questions.
DUNCAN MCKIE: Awesome.
CLANCY CHILDS: It was
that explanatory?
DUNCAN MCKIE: Cool.
CLANCY CHILDS: OK.
Or we could do the whole
thing again.
OK.
Yeah.
Do you mind taking the
mike so people--
AUDIENCE: I guess lots of us are
thinking sort of what data
sources are next, then.
Is there a schedule for them
or a priority for them?
CLANCY CHILDS: You mean other
Google data sources?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
CLANCY CHILDS: We can only
really comment on the ones
that we work on, on AdSense
and Analytics.
But I think it's pretty clear
to see that BigQuery is
Google's big data query and
analysis tool, so I think it's
reasonable to assume that other
products will be looking
forward to getting their data
in there to get it into the
hands of data scientists.
AUDIENCE: Are there any limits
to the size, the number of
rows in the data sets?
CLANCY CHILDS: In BigQuery?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CLANCY CHILDS: There
are some limits.
They're very high.
I don't have offhand
the numbers.
I know that you can get things
like trillions of rows of data
into tables, and that in some
cases, if you try to export a
lot of data at once, you
might hit a limit.
So sometimes you have to just
make sure that you're not
doing a select star across
terabytes of data, which might
not be able to output.
But for specific questions on
BigQuery and the other things,
the Cloud Sandbox on the second
floor might be able to
give more detail.
It's also all posted online.
Sorry I don't have the
exact answer for you.
Great.
So again, these are the places
go to get more information.
And if you do have a second,
there's a QR code in the back
for rating the session.
We'd always appreciate any
feedback you have about the
session, so if you can
fill out there.
And we'll be down in the Ad
Sandbox as well if you have
any other questions you want
to ask us in person.
Thank you very much
for your time.
We really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]